- [Voiceover] All right, part b.
A fresh zinc air cell is
weighed on an analytical balance
before being placed in
a hearing aid for use.
As the cell operates,
does the mass of the cell
increase, decrease, or remain the same?
Justify your answer to
part b one, or b i, b one
in terms of the equation for
the overall cell reaction.
So let's just think about
it for a little bit.
Does the mass of the
cell increase, decrease,
or remain the same?
Well, let's go to our
original reaction over here.
This is our total reaction.
The zinc is part of the metal air cell,
so that would contribute
to its weight beforehand,
and then it reacts with the oxygen.
Well, where is this oxygen coming from?
Well, this is oxygen
is coming from the air
and essentially gets
incorporated into the zinc.
So, before, the oxygen is in the air,
but then after the reaction,
after the total reaction,
it gets incorporated with the
zinc, I guess I should say,
not into the zinc, of course.
It gets incorporated with
the zinc as zinc oxide,
and so now, the oxygen
is part of the cell.
Part, or contributes
to weight of the cell.
So, contributes,
contributes to
the weight,
the weight of cell.
It doesn't contribute before the reaction,
but it contributes after the reaction.
So our, the mass, and
I guess you could say,
the weight, is going to increase.
So I'll just write increase.
And part two, we need
to justify our answer
in terms of the equation for
the overall cell reaction.
So let me just write the
overall cell reaction.
So, two zinc molecules
react with one molecular oxygen,
one O_two, to yield
two zinc oxide,
two zinc oxide molecules.
Well, what we could say is,
is that this was not part
of cell before reaction,
not part of
cell before reaction.
It's coming from the air.
Before reaction.
And then we could say, part
of cell after reaction.
Part of cell
after reaction.
And we could write it
out in words, if we like.
After reaction.
And so I could say, oxygen,
oxygen comes from air,
from, from air,
air to be incorporated
into the zinc oxide,
to be incorporated
into zinc oxide
which then contributes to weight of cell,
or to the mass of cell.
Which then contributes
to mass of cell,
to mass
of cell.
All right, I think I feel
pretty good about that.
Now let's do part c.
The zinc-air cell is taken
to the top of a mountain
where the air pressure is lower.
Will the cell potential be
higher, lower, or the same
as the cell potential
at the lower elevation?
Justify your answer to the first part
based on the equation for
the overall cell reaction
and the information above.
Well, let me just write the
overall cell reaction again.
So let me, the overall cell reaction.
I'll rewrite it again.
So we have two zinc molecules.
Let me write that a little bit neater.
Two, and I wrote it messier.
Two zinc molecules.
One molecular oxygen.
We're going to have this
ingrained in our brain
by the time this is done,
I'm writing it so frequently.
We get two zinc oxides.
Two zinc oxides.
And so what's going to happen
if we go to the top of a mountain
where the air pressure is lower,
we have just fewer air
molecules in general.
That means we're also going to
have lower oxygen molecules.
So we could say that the
partial pressure of oxygen
is going to be lower.
So we could say, partial pressure
of reactant will be lower.
Partial pressure.
There's just going to be fewer
oxygen molecules from the air
being able to bump and react
with the zinc molecules.
Well, actually, it's not
reacting with the zinc molecules,
as we saw in the original reactions,
when we look at the half reactions.
Fewer reactions from the air
just bumping in the right way
with the water molecules
and actually the electrons
that are coming in through the circuit,
you're just going to have fewer of them
bouncing around, being
able to do this reaction.
So you could say partial pressure,
partial pressure of reactant.
Or maybe I'll say partial pressure,
or you could also do the
concentration of the reaction,
there's going to be just, reactant.
There's going to be less of it around.
Partial pressure or we
can say concentration,
concentration lower,
lower,
so lower,
so lower cell potential.
Lower cell,
cell potential.
So actually, I just did it in reverse.
I answered part two first.
And so part one is lower.
So we're gonna have a
lower cell potential.
Lower cell potential.
It's really important to get
the conceptual understanding
of why it's happening.
Remember, when we look
at the half reaction,
what's happening,
what is happening at our cathode,
we have oxygen coming in from the air,
and it gets into the kind of
pores of this porous substance,
and when the oxygen,
the O_2 molecules bump
in just the right way with the water
and the electrons coming in,
they just kind of go together, and react,
you get your hydroxide,
for they react to form the hydroxide.
Now if you have less, you know,
at a lower elevation, you're
gonna have a lot of oxygen.
You're gonna have a high partial pressure
of the molecular oxygen.
So there are a lot of them
(mumbles) moment in time
are going to be available
to bounce around and react.
But if you go to a higher elevation,
you're just gonna have
fewer of these characters.
So you're gonna have
So you're going to have a lower
partial pressure of oxygen,
or you could think of
it as you have a lower
concentration of oxygen inside the pores,
so it's gonna be harder for
this reaction to move forward.
And you can think about
the extreme situation.
What if you were going to
a super high elevation.
If you were eventually going into space,
where you have very little oxygen
or no oxygen at all, well then,
then the reaction's
going to stop altogether.
So hopefully, hopefully that,
that makes, let me just
go back to part c here.
I'm having trouble with my, oh,
this, then I go back to part c.
And there you go.